(birds chirping)
- [Narrator] The people
of Singapore love birds,
and none more so than this man.
(foreign language)
(cheerful music)
This is Ting Lang Fu, the
owner of one of Singapore's
premier birdcage making shops.
(foreign language)
Many of Lang Fu's cages can
be found across the street,
at a gathering of the Kebun
Baru Birdsinging Club.
Each weekend, the club sees Singaporeans
from all over coming together.
(foreign language)
But people do more than just sit
and admire the beautiful birds.
Frequently, there are
bird singing competitions,
where a variety of birds are
judged on singing ability,
tonal quality, stamina,
liveliness and beauty.
(foreign language)
(upbeat music)